now i don't stand before you bulletproof
because eating marijuana and smoking
marijuana might as well be two goddamn
different [ __ ] drugs
my problem is i have to take so much for
it to get me and that it's not fun
because i'm way [ __ ] up so my cousin
hit me up recently he's turning 40 and
he's like look man i'm feeling my
[ __ ] age
and i would really like to go out just
the two of us and do something together
something like we used to do back in the
day i'm like okay what do you have in
mind he's like why don't we go ride
roller coasters i was like
i don't know about that
we might be too old for today's roller
coaster
and he got mad he's like i'm calling you
to tell you i'm too old and now you're
telling me we're too old you know what
[ __ ] it you're right you're right we're
family i got your back let's go make a
day out of this [ __ ] so we drive out to
magic mountain in california and we get
there right when the park opens okay and
he pulls out a parking space and he puts
the car in the park and he looks at me
and he goes hey and it was a shady hay
sound a lot like an alcohol
right
and he goes we should eat these before
we go in there i look down in his lap
and he's got these two [ __ ] brownies
they're like this big and this thick and
i'm like dude there's no [ __ ] way i'm
going in that part
until both those brownies are gone
so we each
have a full [ __ ] marijuana brownie
and we get in line for the first ride of
the day called tatsu okay it's a roller
coaster and it's probably 9
17 right we waiting for 45 minutes 45
minutes coincidentally happens to be the
perfect amount of time for that weed
brownie to give me incredible anxiety
and not just about this roller coaster
i'm watching go by all kinds of weird
[ __ ] and decisions i've ever made in my
life
just rolling through like why do i wash
my hands before i do dirty dishes
what the [ __ ] happened to tan m m's
it's like we went to dead one night woke
up tan m m's was gone
well i'll tell you what happened to him
y'all
1995 mars decided that two [ __ ]
browns was redundant they got rid of tan
put a vote out to the public apparently
we all voted blue
i looked it up for this [ __ ] joke
just i was acting
not just telling you funny [ __ ] i'm
funny funny [ __ ] with facts
now it's our turn to get on this roller
coaster i'm gonna walk you through it
okay you start standing right and i say
to the high school kid yo where do we
sit and he just looks at me he starts
standing i like he started doing that
[ __ ] 45 minutes ago
you know like i didn't know that was
part of the experience
so then i pulled that bar over my chest
and i don't know how you all do it but i
click it with enough room to breathe and
then i test myself on the fall
just to the shoulder i'm like
okay
i click it again that's how i do it oh
my god
i click it again
okay okay all right
all right
but i hear this voice say
i think we can slide out of this
okay my cousin's just as scared as i am
and i took comfort in that and i look
over at my cousin
my cousin didn't say [ __ ]
and i hear it again i hear hey man i
think we can slide out as we
oh my god
it's the weed brownie talking to me
right now
and it was as scared as i was
and i'm not gonna lie i took comfort in
that and i had to enter dialogue back
with that brown i was like brookie you
really think we decided
i'm pretty sure we can slide out of this
you think i'm doing my tests
like that
you think i should say something to
somebody like [ __ ] yeah you should say
something to somebody
but what i didn't realize is i have been
saying all of that out loud
oh
and here comes that [ __ ] high school
pick and this [ __ ] bruce lee's
the bar and it extra clicks tight and i
can't breathe and i start [ __ ]
myself like oh my god
i don't want to do this
i don't want to do
this some guy up front's like dude
follow your pride
and i was like hey dick i did when i
started crying
what the [ __ ] do you need out of me back
here
and then these saloon doors close over
your chest and a bar hits you right here
across the [ __ ] knees and then they
lower you and now i'm hanging
horizontally nothing down here this bar
going up to a track this is all just
open space
and i feel like i'm hanging in a [ __ ]
pterodactyls claw getting ready to be
flown off for breakfast
and i'm freaking the [ __ ] out
and i just start heart blinking you know
when you're harping
but it doesn't help but you feel like
it's good you're like [ __ ]
i'm hard blinking and nothing happened
[Applause]
and then i just had this moment of
clarity where i was like well get a
[ __ ] hold of yourself you [ __ ]
you've had weed a ton of times you just
ate it it's the same drug calm the [ __ ]
down but you're right
you're right
[Music]
look at your cousin he's probably fine
and i looked over at my cousin my cousin
is laser focused okay
looks like he died two days ago
that gray ass blue [ __ ] but he was ready
to end up
i go back to the hard place like oh my
god and they shoot us out of this tunnel
up this [ __ ] hill i swear to god was
so high i saw two birds that were like
you got to be [ __ ]
right at the top my cousin snaps out of
me goes i want out i go right now
watch you look down right now
[ __ ]
welcome to 40. it's all downhill from
here
14 loops in like two [ __ ] seconds
okay it was simulated death on a roller
coaster
and when we were done i'm not
embarrassed to tell any of you they had
to help me out
they had to help me out down on one knee
like oh my god
oh my god and teenagers sprinting around
me to get right back on the [ __ ]
thing and i'm like oh my god
this is a microcosm of my whole life
right here man
i made terrible decisions terrible one
after the other
and i slowly i got up and my cousin came
over
and angrily he said i'm sorry
maybe we are too old for this
and i was like nah [ __ ] that we're
definitely too high for this okay
definitely but we're not too old for
this [ __ ] that i'm trying to tell you
these aren't the roller coasters of
yesteryear basically a decepticon just
raped us in the sky
and magic mountain should thank us for
not [ __ ] on this quadrant of their
park
and we hit the log flume and the bumper
cars and called it a day [ __ ] tatsu
y'all [ __ ] that suit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]